today our test driver
I know Dyson Ophir is going to give us
some tips on how to drive safely in snow
and in the mountains more and more SUVs
with all-wheel-drive are on the road
including family oriented station wagons
like the C at Lyon experienced but I
hold underscores that even all-wheel
drive can't repeal the laws of physics
it's a big help when starting up on snow
or ice but braking is another matter if
you're starting out on a slippery
surface Reinhold recommends putting the
car in second gear to keep your wheels
from spinning second gear puts less
torque on the driving wheels and during
your drive to shift up early even if the
engine struggles a bit for the same
reason you don't want your wheels to
spin high rpms should be taboo with a
cold engine anyway just after starting
many moving parts are not optimally
lubricated yet and that means increased
wear our car Chester says that if you
drive lots of short distances especially
in winter you should check your oil
frequently because if the engine doesn't
warm up properly fuel and condensation
water can mix in with the oil and that
reduces the oils lubricating capacity
increasing wear
whether winter or summer it's better to
change your oil frequently than to risk
damage to your engine in snow or ice use
your brakes as seldom as possible it's
better to use the engine brake if the
car has cruise control don't use it in
such weather using the brakes shuts
cruise control off and that increases
the danger of skidding if you're not
confident about how you handle a car in
cold condition says Reinhold just find
an open space and test how your vehicle
responds on ice or snow practice
steering and braking and get a feel for
controlling the car in these conditions
this is especially advisable if you've
rented a car for a ski trip and are not
yet on familiar terms with it
avoid stopping on a slope because
starting up again is harder uphill I
know it has a tip if you do have to stop
on an incline put the foot mats under
the driving wheels then gently roll
forward don't pick up speed too fast
because your passenger has to retrieve
the mats but the all-wheel drive sadly
on experience can manage slopes
in snow packed down by traffic keep a
close eye on where you drive hazardous
sheets of ice can form under the snow
then mondo if you do find yourself on
ice
don't panic says hi noise don't jerk the
steering wheel back and forth don't
brake suddenly just steer very gently to
the right or left to give your tyres a
chance to grip the road again and a car
like the sadly own experience your
electronic assistance will help you be
especially careful at intersections
braking cars have packed the surface and
make it slick
so keep more distance from the vehicle
in front of you and brake gently and
early if you are driving with ABS you'll
have to floor the brakes and steer
carefully I know it has one more tip
getting up the hill is one thing but
you'll have to come back down if your
car starts sliding the wheels are
blocked ease up on the brakes your
automatic control systems don't function
unless they recognize that the wheels
are turning enough to move the car at 3
kilometers an hour only then can they
help out done you are done can a 7
you